people like you know my nearest they
love my patients in it I think it was
clear to them you know in the lyrics of
easy on me that it was like I abided my
time Adele dropped her first single in
five years on Thursday titled easy on me
[Music]
baby
[Music]
now she's dishing on what her nearest
and dearest think of the highly personal
track it's been a complete World room on
Friday the Grammy winner sat down for a
chat with BBC Radio one's Greg James to
talk about the lead single of her highly
anticipated album 30 out November 19th
I'm just so eager like for this for the
easy on me to come out and then for the
album to come out and stuff like that
and for just to exist for my truth just
to exist in the world so yeah I'm
buzzing well easy on me is now out and
while it's getting rave reviews from
fans some of Adele's friends seemingly
had mixed reviews I've sent a snippet of
me singing it as I was writing it to
three of my closest friends here and one
didn't like it the other one was like
well yeah maybe keep trying though you
know
you're working so that was the perfect
um response for me but the rest of
Adele's Inner Circle well they love it
people like you know my nearest they
love my patience in it like you know and
like I'm such an Egypt person like you
know I'll be like I don't like it don't
forget it all those things and I'm like
that with my music I'm like that with
like just things I want to do I'm like
that with my feelings and stuff like
that and it was I think it was clear to
them you know in the lyrics of easy on
me that it was like I buy did my time
like you know and I wasn't reacting you
know to a reaction or anything like that
it was just it was just you know a
feeling that I'd sort of stirred on for
a while Adele revealed during a recent
Instagram live that a lot of her new
music would be about her 2019 split from
her ex-husband Simon kaneki what's my
next album gonna be based on
um divorce babe divorce so most of the
time you know even like just for like my
best friends and even my manager their
first reaction no matter what a song is
is it's just nice to hear you sing and
we couldn't agree more I feel amazing
about it like she said the 33 year old
hello singer who's also a mom to
nine-year-old son Angelo doesn't make
music during her time off so what has
Adele been up to I've been obviously I'm
on the school run and stuff like that
you know I love cooking and stuff like
that I love hanging out with my friends
and like getting a bit drunk after
bedtime and stuff like that and like
chatting absolute nonsense
um I love films that you know I've
always I've always spent most of my time
watching films and stuff like that but
just very very mundane safe to say
things are about to rev up for Adele as
the countdown to 30 is on but looking
ahead she said there may come a time
where she no longer makes music I won't
be doing this forever like I don't want
to do it forever and also people won't
want me to do it forever thankfully that
day is not today so for now we'll just
be here blasting easy on me on repeat
thank you
[Music]